hi I'm Greg e hi I'm Dan sir
Greggy greggy's
that's what uh ladies calling no no one
why do that that's a terribly Greggy
that's my good man yes today a great
girl treasurer and you know my classy
British and they don't Greg a boy so my
ears did you carry out all their sweet
no chin your wheel or will so you just
lost all your UK yeah I think about
doing one built it so we all found
Mickey enough coach peanut be put out a
request wanting me to react to some
Conan
so I say shirt I found out amber rose
plaster is huge on the convo medication
I am she loved going teen Coco I think
ginger just because it's coming that's
you're not a real ginger that's
disappointing
yeah you lying yeah yeah total without
borders made in Mexico ah Without
Borders shrimp and the border in the
wall because Trump wants more borders
more borders more less Mexican less
Mexican let Mexican food that's next
week well more Taco Bell dough would be
great
according well let me eat KFC I don't
know well there's some Taco Bell's or a
KFC and talk about pizza
it's talk about any ween stopped let's
watch it let's get into it
all these precious man walking across
the desert
[Music]
Hey when I saw the whole thing
oh I like a thriller
because Ryan Colonel Brian onion needed
t do a big showing doesn't $17 a
meatball
Americans are subject to extreme very
extremely day you might just be one of
those bad on breaks there I see what
you're doing alright we got some new
people running the United States and
that's created some tension between our
countries Tim look all Americans into
one brief unfair
Oh gracias thank you so much oh my god
they're like 15 years ago
okay and I stole it out when you
probably in Bali and I would see myself
through the border this is a great
okay the dog was actually gonna tackle
well I gotta watch these code in series
man uh so Kalyan is doing a thing for
like the month of March I think where
he's doing his entire show in a Mexican
studio hiring Mexican crew oh really
hiring as many Mexican actors as we can
to to let go and be like well let's just
address this through comedy yeah what
the Mexican perspective is on this but
that's putting white people out of work
I guess what that help call him what the
hell coming what the hell you know we
need those jobs no we need those jobs
all of them yeah I don't know i we
minted a little too far um I like that I
love that Conan does he's awesome like
Travel Channel remotes these days like
he did one where he went to Germany he
did when we went to Korea it's not a lot
actually now he's in Mexico like this is
so cool
my favorites are the remotes where he's
actually out interacting with people on
the street trying out new things I'm
comfortable being uncomfortable making
people uncomfortable yeah they bring up
well he's like 700 feet taller than
everyone yeah sure in the country of
Mexico surprise I've never seen him in
person he really is one of my heroes
he's one of my heroes like I know I saw
this before off-camera but one of my
favorite things about Conan is when he
breaks when he messes up and makes fun
of themselves yeah I think he's the
world's best Helen cover um jokes
self-deprecating humor is the master of
yeah I love what yeah especially he does
like even an opening monologue in the
joke doesn't go well but you really I'm
gonna make fun of himself see like I
call that the last yeah I used to watch
when he was on NBC like yes late night
yeah and that's what he really came into
like fruition like a lot of college kids
got into him I like mine tedious but
because he like kind of accepted this
sort of like underdog status yeah that
has worked really well for him totally
yeah
he has a very specific audience and like
Conan fans are loyal unlike any other
talk show host and yeah I think Jimmy
Kimmel but great Tonight Show host I
think he's great he was really good at
the Oscars yeah he's really gonna be a
no Jimmy Kimmel
he cannot defeat him
okay Jimmy Fallon is this a nice show
you think it was on ABC yet Jimmy Kimmel
is great I think Jimmy Fallon's great
too
I don't feel like their fanbase has
quite like you know like we have like
team cocoa and all that for a Conan I
don't feel like Kimmel or Fallon has
that or separate matters it has Connie
to that sound what comes the best he's
also had to go through the interesting
Tonight Show struggle Oh which made it
all really root for him but it's so
fascinating because I didn't really care
for him when he was The Tonight Show
host I felt like he and he talked about
how he did like kind of tone himself
down a little bit as he was trying to
adjust with it Tonight Show audience
this is different kind of format or not
everyone can deliver that broadly yeah
and I don't think he can I'd like the
idea of him doing it but the way he was
going about it I could see why I wasn't
that strong yeah but so I just feel
[ __ ] up how you know he got kicked how
he had to leave and everything pretty
rude to let out rumor is they're rude
nasty woman yeah very rare everyone
knows Jay Leno is standard but after you
got the TV s like I felt like you really
made it his own and it was better than
he's ever been even on late-night
changed because he had to go through
this awful experience not being on TV
for like a year or something like you're
part of an era track he cared less any
and he found more ways to make fun of
himself yeah and make fun of the whole
thing it was his idea I don't give a
[ __ ] anymore I'm just gonna do what I
want and say what I want and I think
it's really benefited for him and now
he's even doing more experiments like
when you're on to the Tonight Show you
can't keep traveling the world and [ __ ]
and doing that crazy remotes you got to
be based at the studio so now you have a
TV show he has time to do they allow him
to leniency to go out and do these crazy
things which you need to do because I
feel like he's such a weirdo we need to
explore that weird marine or he says hey
I want to do a show in Mexico and I want
to have Mexican translators for
everything that I say well I'm down
there exactly which I know about because
my friend Liza is doing the voice of
Andy Richter
which is really cool and I was like
that's so random who wouldn't think of
that Conan Conan
Coco and he was an NBC we would not have
that i tol amber
earlier I would not want to go to a
taping because my first time meeting
Conan will be in an interview when I
earn it man who does reactions correct
out because of it no but I feel like you
love him so much that you would not
regret seeing him in the audience and
what is Nora trying to fix me
why kind of fix me terrific job we got
stop that yeah I reveal something to
Greg earlier and he's using it I was
trying to figure you by trying to get
you to stop fixing me I'm trying to
forget you to Conan I'm just trying to
get you to get invited on Conan is all
I'm saying over the other would premiere
I want you at it with premier I want you
to fix your life and be on Conan one way
or another
thanks amber you welcome I'll be back
with more thing yeah thanks again I'm
sure write a list and I'll get to it
yeah well guys I'm Greg subscribe to the
real rejects get accepted today that's
how reload another fire you know an
improv like when people do this and guns
atronics just do that yes yeah yeah it's
real improv for you guys like when you
answer a phone Dennis on phone maybe
this is not a ho maybe dudes oh yeah all
improv yes n we do any what where one ah
amber is on the amber plaster Channel
Yammer tell them about your channel oh I
don't want to do it yeah I do think my
youtube channel is youtube.com slash
amber plastered twenty two and two to my
favorite number that's how old she is t2
she's very young cheese on cheese yeah
shoes on and uh
gift Watchers get plastered plaster that
needs to be a series I don't yet very
has implications okay it does I have a
react series that now called Star Wars
react where me and when my co-hosts from
afterbuzz TV realize people tend to
watch Star Wars so we did we watched it
for the first time and then had our very
in-depth reviews of our thoughts about
Star Wars and then at the end of the
journey
we kind of became star wars fans of
certain movies but it was certainly a
very ignorant journey there so some of
the movies some of the we got reactors
super-crunchy and some of them are like
really well thought out indeed yeah so
enjoy that do that reactors with your
host so so hope that Renee Arielle and
I'm going to be doing a new react series
planning for Resident Evil with YouTube
or Alex Len Wars which she works at whoo
ha ha
I will never guess are on her champion
no you won't yeah that's good good yet
bad yeah